liebe genossinnen kenntnis nicht höre
hier sehr aufmerksam zu
heute einmal zwerg sein damit morgen
wieder etwas großes rauskommt hat kevin
gesagt ich vermisse etwas an erläuterung
dazu was ist das etwas was ist das etwas
große darauf fehlt jede antwort hier von
den kritikern des weiterverhandeln
was ist das große ich habe vorgestern
sebastian hartmann war dabei und kann es
bezeugen am flughafen gemessen
da kam der ältere frau auf mich zu und
sagte zu mir frau nahles
wie geht denn das aus am sonntag ich bin
selber betroffen 35 jahre gearbeitet
wenig verdient ich setze auf sie ich
möchte unbedingt dass diese grundrente
kommt und sebastian und wird es
bestätigen können und ich habe mit der
frau geredet sagte kämpfen dafür dass
ist vielleicht in den augen von vielen
hier zu bleiben
aber für diese frau ist es was großes
was sie erreichen können ganz konkret
und ich bin in dieser partei weil ich
was großes im kleinen
immer gesehen hab im fortschritt ganz
konkreten millionen von menschen
durch diese
[Applaus]
leute die vom himmlischen profitieren
nicht alle spd will gewählt haben am
ende habe ich trotzdem gedacht das war
richtig und dafür bin ich in dieser
partei und ich sage euch was ist denn
etwas großes ich habe ganz klar an
dieser stelle und er blutete das herz
und der karl weiß das und die mahnung
wir haben darum stunde lang gerungen
nichts davon zurückzunehmen es gibt
keine begründung warum man aktien
privatversicherten das 2 5-fache
abrechnen kann und für den ak mitglied
sie mich nicht das wird auch in zukunft
so bleiben wie wir können mit den
konservativen nicht alles durchsetzen
deswegen sind wir doch eigenständige
partei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die sich auf in dem moment wo wir uns
entscheiden mit den anderen zu regieren
und wenn wir das in der vergangenheit
nicht gut genug gemacht haben unsere
eigene position das haben wir viele
vorgetragen
dann habt ihr recht ich sage das für
mich selbst ich war sehr ehrgeizig im
abarbeiten der verhandlungsergebnisse
weil ich gedacht habe das bringt uns am
ende genug profil und das ist nicht so
das ist die eine wahrheit wir haben
tatsächlich nicht genug eigene profil
gehabt haben auch kommunikative fehler
möglicherweise gemacht ja es ist aber
genauso richtig dass wir gleichzeitig
sehr erfolgreich waren in vielem was wir
umgesetzt haben auch richtig
die dritte wahrheit ist aber und damit
müssen uns auseinandersetzen
das ist tatsächlich so ist dass wir auch
in der letzten opposition nur von 23 auf
25 0 7% gekommen sind
da kann man nicht von einer blühenden
erholung in der opposition reden und die
wahrheit ist auch dass viele unserer
europäischen nachbarn
sozialdemokratischen parteien ob sie nun
regiert haben oder nicht in derselben
mal hängen denn offensichtlich und das
ist das was wir an der neuerung brauchen
ist es uns bisher nicht gelungen die den
liegend antworten auf die zukunft zu
geben den leuten die ängste zu nehmen
und mehr vertrauen zu den er ihnen aber
was um alles in der welt hat mit der
merkel den blöden dobrindt und den
anderen zu tun
schließlich das problem mit müssen
das lösen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich will und möchte keine neuwahlen
wir haben viele gesagt gerade der
vorredner habt ihr angst vor neuwahlen
ich habe nicht angst vor neuem ich habe
angst vor den fragen der bürgerinnen und
bürger wenn wir in neuwahlen reingehen
nämlich ganz einfache frage werden das
seien ganz einfache fragen der
bürgerinnen und bürger werden dass sein
wir werden noch ob wir werden nicht bis
in den nächsten drei monaten wenn die
neuwahlen kommen und das ist die avatar
kommt rum wohin genau darin kommt werden
wir mit demselben programm dann stehen
da werden wir doch die
bürgerversicherung obendrauf packt und
die sachgrundlose befristung klar und
sagen wir ja das ist unser programm das
an die bürger aber davon hättet ihr das
meiste doch machen können da sagen wir
aber nicht 100 prozent und soll ich euch
mal was sagen was ich glaube was die
bürger runtermachen die zeigen uns ein
vogel
[Applaus]
so werden die bürgerinnen und bürger
dann sagen die spd die macht jetzt nur
noch politik wenn sie die absolute
mehrheit bekommt oder die spd setzt auf
ein wackliges linksbündnis von dem wir
wie alle hier im raum wissen dass es
momentan keine gesellschaftliche und
keine parlamentarische mehrheit hat das
ist doch verdammt noch mal
[Applaus]
das einzige was ich euch hier
versprechen kann allen wir werden die
koalitionsverhandlungen ärzten
verhandeln heißt auch wieder über
sachgrundlose befristung auch wieder
voll klauser ist auch für mich über
bürgerversicherung wir werden verhandeln
bis es quietscht auf der anderen seite
alles andere kann ich euch nicht
versprechen
ich weiß auch nicht ob wir dann 100
prozent von dem was wir gerne wollen hat
nach hause nein das werden wir
wahrscheinlich oft einig aber wir werden
verhalten und wir werden weitere gute
sachen raus holen und dafür lohnt es
sich am ende heute mit ja zu stimmen
vielen dank das war ein ausgesprochen -
premier für weitere verhandlungen durch
die fraktionschefin der spd andrea
nahles für auch generalsekretärin der
partei die glaube ich die partei kennt
wie kaum eine andere umarmung und dank
von martin schulz für diese für diesen
engagierten auftritt sie weist darauf
hin ja was wird denn passieren wenn die
spd ihn ein sagt und es zu neuwahlen
kommt die zahlen verheißen im moment
jedenfalls nichts gutes denn die spd
sicherlich den umfragen bei rund 18
prozent
ob es dazu kommt so sollte diesen
neuwahlen wird sich dann im laufe dieses
nachmittages hier noch zeigen
[Applaus]